you
hi everyone is Gerry I'm on tactics
trainer again I'm gonna try it three
more puzzles and this first one I think
I've seen before
okay black to move just gonna share my
thoughts along the way here so material
is balanced okay white is up upon this
night is being attacked multiple
checking moves hmm this night is under
fire so so too is this knight on e5
checking moves involve rook takes knight
Knight g1 most likely not the case
Knight g5 probably not best either
Knight check be my with Knight takes
Knight and there's still this issue on
e5 so how can I meet the threat on the
knight and throw a strong punch at white
hmm I wonder
hmm for a second I was thinking about
rook g4 h4 but that's not really working
rook g4 pawn takes Knight rook h4 King G
to the knight is attacked so rook h2 is
not working for me if the knight was
defended that would work there might be
something to that though I wonder
okay sure what else to consider as a
first move what about just rook takes
Knight rook takes Knight pawn takes
Knight and then yeah that's not really
working I was thinking there might be
just the simple recapture to clear the
sixth rank for rook h6
I doubt that that's going to work I
think this is one that's going to
require some quiet move along the way
which is a pain they're difficult to
spot hmm I'm running out of candidate
moves here really Knight somewhere huh
this is tricky hmm kind of stumped here
I was stumped in the last set of three
puzzles the second of three puzzles was
stumping me and this one's getting me
right off the bat
let's see rook takes Knight pawn takes
Knight got to get the material back as
why if rook takes on e6 and then yeah
I'm not seeing good follow up after that
huh I'm ready to throw in the towel with
this one to be honest
Oh oh no no no maybe I'm not maybe I'm
not hang on for a second okay maybe I
should have started with the fact that
the King is only safe on h3 and he only
has one legal move from this car
position he could only go to G - so what
about as a start Knight g6 the night is
still attacked and there's the idea
where if the knight moves we play Knight
f4 and that's mate the night from f4
would guard these two squares I think
that's it I really do think that's it
just 9th g6 I probably should have seen
that sooner moves like d5 to defend the
knight are not working because you could
just take and Knight f4 would be
checkmate I think this is it okay that
is it you know you take the knight I
probably should have seen that much
sooner and that's me okay um let's just
go in the second one okay two of three
all right White's in a pen that's nice
so my first thought is not to take but
attack the knight hmm how does white
untangle from this position actually is
this not going to contribute at all okay
let's see my first
is believe it or not Knight b6 because
I'm seeing a way where you can get to c4
with tempo and then there's that ever so
appealing III Square since it would be
with check and also a fork I don't know
that you could really dislodge the Queen
from our strong position on e4
white is in a knot currently and I'm not
even sure what a good follow-up would be
for white after nine to be six it seems
like he's going astray but this night c4
with tempo 93 to follow what do you do
to deal with that here's one line Knight
b6 Queen f2 so that the king could
finally move the knight would have
enough defenders Knight b6 Queen f2
let's say Knight c4 and if King G 193
hits the rook and if the rook moves
there's rook takes Knight however let me
back up for a second Knight b6 what
about what about after Knight b6 Queen
to e1 no that's not working Knight b6
Queen e1 is met with Brooke takes Knight
if cook takes rook Queen takes Queen if
Queen takes Queen pawn takes Queen and
the pawn is there to defend the rook so
I think this is it Knight b6 to c4 I
don't think going in this direction is
helpful I think you I think you want to
go on a path where you see it would take
the same number of moves f6g for e3
three moves but in this direction that
second move is with tempo with an attack
I want to go with this one
that is correct and Knight c4 just
following through and then finally what
just check I'm hanging on
second of course this was my idea a
night check right away but should I be
taking the Queen first Queen takes Queen
is not going to be at night check King
to the first rank if night checking here
Queen g4 is mate so night to e3 check
King g1 and now there's back rank issues
oh no no no the same idea I'm sorry I'm
sorry why am i apologizing okay no just
like Queen e1 earlier that I was
pointing out could be met with rook
takes night so too can Queen to e2 in
this case I know I'm mistaken again
let's see rook takes Knight rook takes
rook is no good
drop the Queen Queen takes Queen is not
good because of pond takes however after
rook takes Knight Queen takes then what
do you have up your sleeve Knight check
at that point with then King to g1 I'm
not sure let me see I'm so close with
this one
Queen to somewhere no Knight check or
Brooke takes Knight or my candidate
moves at this point rook takes Knight
Queen takes rook and
why am I not seeing it hmm I'm stumped
here night check rook takes night not
thinking clearly right now trying to
visualize this as best I can
rook takes Knight Queen takes rook 93
check King to g1 Queen here you can give
back the exchange with rook to f1 that
doesn't seem like it's it so naive three
check most likely King g1 and then
then I'm kind of stuck nyeeehhh
kingi one Queen check here could be met
with a knight to e1 why am I not seeing
this III check King g1 just gonna go
with this that is correct
I thought was Queen here what am I
missing though this is no good
rook takes Knight still Queen takes
Queen check here
Knight block
I'm not seeing it I believe that this
must be it no it's not
ouch what is the solution of this one
really Knight to g4 oh man I did not see
that at all
Wow I was so fixated on these checking
moves I see the idea now Hager trying to
deflect the defending of the defender of
f3 huh I was completely blind I did not
even consider Knight g4 at all huh
Knight g4 if Queen takes Queen pawn
takes both rook and Knight are hit black
will be winning material like that
that's the end of the puzzle and that
that's the variation it shows and the
other one well what else do you do if
rip back here you're just losing the
Queen huh
I was completed what a blind spot to
this Knight g4 move hmm okay let's see
if I can get two out of three here's the
last one
okay hmm all right this one should be a
checkmate problem I would think this
King is quite short on squares okay
so checking moves there's Queen g5
there's rook to f1 I think it might be
important to play this move first of
these two moves Queen g5 and rip to f1
one thing I think might be important as
white I think it might be important to
stop the King from getting too eise Evan
because then he's maybe on his way to
running away to d7 so we could insert
this check first and then
after king to f7 play rook to f1 and at
that point what do we do hmm that's when
it gets a little bit tricky let's see
Queen g5 king f7 rook f1 check King g8
what's the follow-up at that point this
Knight is defending g6 otherwise it
would be much much simpler right you
could take that in g6 and then give
checkmate on g7 if this Knight wasn't
around so let's do another run-through
hang on for a second why am I so fixated
on g5 here's another move that will do
similar with new possibilities for the
Queen Queen h4 has this h7 square in
mind I think this is key so instead of
Queen g5 which seems the more appealing
move to be honest since it's in blacks
position it's very close to the king
controlling a lot of squares near the
king but Queen h4 having this h7 square
in mind I think is the key to this
puzzle
let's see though yeah Queen to h4 for a
second I was wondering what if this but
you just take so I think Queen h4 check
King f7 and then I think you shouldn't
give check on f1 but Queen h7 forcing
the King back up to f6
oh we're not even gonna need the rook in
this one I think this is just a queen
and night mate problem Queen h4 king f7
Queen h7 check King f6 and then Queen to
g7 is me huh these guys are the two the
best tandem for attacking the Queen and
Knight pair the Queen to Knight pair the
bishop pair the Queen and Knight pair
these are the two they work very very
well together so I think it is this that
is correct and this is just a maintenace
seven and then that's mate all right we
don't get to see two too many
mate problems usually it's just the
winner material so that was actually an
interesting one I was ready to like you
saw early on I was ready to go in the
wrong direction with Queen to g5 but
slight adjustment having that new
possibility for the Queen was the main
idea with this one I guess okay feel
free to share as usual how you did with
these three and as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you